There are more and more
electric-powered ferries in the world,
at least for short distances,
across rivers or small lakes.
But one of the big problems with them
is that the batteries required
are massive and expensive.
A ferry not only has to move something
the size of a building,
but it's got to push the water
out of the way too,
so you need far more energy
than something like an electric car.
Electric ferries would be
a lot easier to run
if you could just, y'know,
plug them into the mains.
So that's what the
Randers Fjords Ferry in Denmark does:
it has 350 metres of
hardened, waterproof, electrical cable
rolled up on a drum.
One end is connected to the ferry.
The other end is plugged into the
electrical grid, just there,
and as we set off,
all the power for the motors
will be coming from the shore.
IN DANISH:
The most surprising thing for me
is just how quiet this ferry is.
There's no diesel motor
churning away.
And you might be thinking, okay,
what if something snags on the cable?
Well, this was already
a cable-guided ferry,
even before it was electric.
Cable ferries are pretty common
around the world in places like this,
channels with strong currents
or shallow waters.
Instead of being pushed by a propeller,
the boat pulls itself across
by latching onto two cables
laid across the riverbed.
There's not much boat traffic round here,
and there are already clear rules for
how to navigate around cables like that:
basically, don't pass while the ferry's in motion.
We're not going to be seeing this on
ferries across the English Channel
any time soon.
Plug-in boats are obviously going
to be limited to a few situations.
And the biggest fuel-burners are still
massive world-travelling container ships.
But this does feel like
one more step in the right direction.